[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur la télé
france pour 1h30 d'émission nous
décrypterons comme chaque soir du lundi
au jeudi l'essentiel de l'information
avec nos invités et nos reporters une
émission essentiellement consacrée à la
crise du coronavirus en france et dans
le monde
voici les titres le gouvernement
peaufine le déconfinement jean castex
chargé de le coordonner invite à la
prudence alors que de son côté emmanuel
macron a dévoilé aujourd'hui son plan
pour la culture les droits des
intermittents seront prolongés jusqu en
août 2000 21 et un fonds d'indemnisation
pour les séries ou tournages annulé sera
créé l'allemagne elle accélère son
retour à la normale tous les magasins
écoles vont rouvrir en mai le
gouvernement allemand qui autorise
également la reprise du championnat
national de football la bundesliga 1
déconfinement large donc suite aux
pressions croissantes sur un gala mais
recèle merkel par une partie de
l'opinion du monde économique et des
régions de son côté la justice allemande
remettent en cause l'aide financière de
la banque centrale européenne
[Musique]
la russie devient le cinquième pays
d'europe le plus touché par le
coronavirus après avoir recensé plus de
dix mille nouveaux cas en 24 heures mais
elle réfléchit à des mesures de
déconfinement après le premier ministre
mir a aidé michaud steen et le ministre
de la construction
on a appris la contamination de la
ministre de la culture
[Musique]
mais tout d'abord un point sur le bilan
de l'épidémie du virus dans l'hexagone
qui vient de tomber en compte 25 1809
décès au total en france selon le
dernier bilan de la direction générale
de la santé 278 personnes sont mortes en
24 heures le nombre de personnes en
réanimation continue de baisser avec 283
malades en moins du côté de la carte le
département de la sarthe passe désormais
de l'oranje au vert edouard philippe
présentera donc demain à 16 heures les
derniers détails du plan de
déconfinement la crainte d'une deuxième
vague de contamination et pau c'est
possible selon jean castex le monsieur
déconfinement du gouvernement a été
auditionné aujourd'hui devant le sénat
il affirme qu'un plan de re confinement
est sur la table mais que le
comportement des français est la clé de
la réussite écouter il me semble
observer un petit relâchement et c'est
pas bon
le dis c'est pas bon parce que si ça se
prolonge en phase de sortie du
confinement si on ne respecte pas les
fameux gestes barrières la distanciation
fait des règles élémentaires qui sont la
clé de voûte c'est la seule certitude à
8 que nous ayons dans la lutte contre
cette pandémie en risquera la rechute
on est sur la phase 1 du déconfinement
on est donc c'est encore une période où
il faut que nous soyons très
précautionneux le tout c'est qu'on
puisse expliquer à nos concitoyens
pourquoi oui pourquoi non et que tout
relève d'une logique assez cohérente et
pour en parler nous sommes avec gilbert
collard député européen est reine
bonsoir gilbert collard merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france le
comportement des français qui est donc
un la clé de la réussite selon un jean
castex qui souligne qu' un certain
relâchement été remarqué ces derniers
quelle est votre réaction là dessus
c'est vrai qu'on compte beaucoup sur les
français pour la réussite de ce
déconfinement écouter on en a vraiment
l'impression que depuis le début de
cette sinistre pandémie les français
sont des otages des cobayes
on se sert d'eux pour finalement testé
dans la chair dans la souffrance dans la
vie la manière dont il faut soit dans un
premier temps ne rien faire soit dans un
deuxième temps confinés soir dans un
troisième temps des confiné tout en
précisant qu on pourrait être amené à
reconsidérer en réalité il s'agit d'un
déconfinement purement cyniquement
économique et qu'il produira ses fruits
venez 2 par le retour au banc finement
dans quelques temps parce que le virus
n'est pas parti et tant qu'on n'aura pas
les gels tant qu'on n'aura pas à aller
mars quand on tournera pas le vaccin on
fera courir à la population un risque
réel donc je je je crois vraiment que
des français sans les otages de leurs
gouvernements et les cobayes du
confinement et du déconfinement et que
c'est sur leur peau que tout va se jouer
finalement alors gilbert collard qu'est
ce qu'il aurait fallu faire aujourd'hui
en tout cas maintenant qu entre
guillemets c'est trop tard finalement il
aurait fallu rester confiné en attendant
enfin l'arrivée de ces tests massifs qui
ont certainement fait défaut en amont
écoutez d'abord il aurait fallu qu en
descendent quand le président de la
république savait que l'ennemi mortel
était sur le territoire qu'il le dise je
n'arrive pas à comprendre comment et en
informer à ce moment-là de la présence
du virus
il ne l'a il l'a pas dit et comment ils
n'ont pas pris il le gouvernement à
l'ensemble des responsables à la fois
politique et administratif ils n'ont pas
pris les mesures nécessaires pour que
nous ayons en temps utile les mars que
le gel et tout le matériel nécessaire
je pense qu'on aurait dû
attendre pour des confiné faire un
déconfinement purement économique sur
les zones stratégiques éviter d'envoyer
les enfants à l'école parce que je pense
que ça va être très grave de
conséquences vu qu'on a affaire à un
virus qu'on ne connaît pas et je crois
qu'entre la bourse et la vie si vous
voulez il faut toujours choisir la vie
et j'ai peur que ce gouvernement et
voulait choisir et la bourse et la vie
et des conséquences je le crains seront
seront dramatiques je suis très
pessimiste quant aux conséquences de ce
déconfinement gilbert collard vous dit
le gouvernement aurait dû le dire ça
veut dire quoi concrètement
qui ne l'a pas dit par un mensonge par
omission qu'il a sous-estimé tout
simplement selon vous est ce une blague
car oui le comprends mais excusez ma
réaction spontanée réaction de donner
des surprises quand on est le chef de
l'état et qu'on apprend qu'il y à un
ennemi mortel sur le territoire on doit
le dire parce que guru en admettant
qu'on veuille ne pas le dire pour ne pas
affoler les populations ont prendre les
mesures on commande les masques on
commande le gel on déploie toutes les
mesures dans les hôpitaux on prend les
mesures en l'occurrence on a choisi des
élections municipales à la passe et on
maintient les élections municipales
voilà bon de dire que tout cela arrivera
devant une cour pénale je vous l'autre
parce que les morts ne pardonne pas et
je pense qu'on a on a affaire à des
amateurs quoi vraiment on l'a dit on est
en guerre mais c'est la 7ème compagnie
qui va au combat
on a affaire à des amateurs qui un jour
disent oui un jour 19 tout à l'heure
j'ai entendez le monsieur déconfinement
vous arriver à comprendre ce qui veut
dire quand il dit il faut que les
français comprennent pourquoi on dit oui
pourquoi on dit non le zoo ça veut dire
quoi on va écouter gilbert collard
edouard philippe qui donne peut-être un
début d'explication pour lui
il faut justement trouvé un bon
équilibre entre risques sanitaires et
des confinement le chemin de crête sur
lequel nous nous trouvons est un chemin
qui nous impose de tenir un équilibre
entre la sécurité sanitaire et la
reprise entre les deux c'est un
équilibre
c'est toujours difficile de maintenir un
équilibre mais vous voyez bien et vous
savez pertinemment que si nous donnons
la priorité à l'un en oubliant l'autre
nous risquons de très mauvaises
nouvelles de très mauvaises nouvelles
vous savez parfaitement monsieur le
président la catastrophe sociale qui
s'annonce et qui serait encore pire si
nous restions indéfiniment confiné vous
le savez vous la vivez dans votre
département enfin tout le monde la vie
tout le monde la sente monde la voit
arriver nous devons donc reprendre la
production
nous devons donc reprendre la vie
sociale nous devons donc reprendre
l'école parce que sinon c'est la
catastrophe
et nous savons aussi que si nous allons
trop vite par enthousiasme par
imprudence en privilégiant cette fois ci
la reprise sur la sécurité sanitaire
nous risquons dans ce cas là de très
mauvaises nouvelles sanitaires et
gilbert collard tout même vous
n'accordez pas un petit peu de bon sens
à ce que vient de déclarer le premier
ministre
d'abord d'abord je n'arrive pas à
comprendre qu'on puisse assimiler la
fonction politique à celle d'un d'un
funambule parce que dessous le funambule
il ya toujours le fracas du vide
franchement la métaphore est pour le
moins effrayante qu'il y ait un
impératif économique
on est tous conscients il faudrait être
complètement abrutis pour ne pas se
rendre compte que la situation
économique est dramatique et qu'il faut
réanimer l'économie aussi mais faut-il
le faire dans cette précipitation
faut-il le faire sans organisation parce
que on parle de la reprise
de l'activité dans les écoles mais les
écoles ne sont pas prêtes on parle de la
reprise de l'activité dans les
entreprises mais c'est encore sur les
épaules des chefs d'entreprise que tout
repose on sait même pas comment la sncf
va pouvoir organiser les transports
alors qu'elle dit elle même que si elle
doit respecter la distanciation exiger
les transports ne sont plus rentables
enfin il ya un chaos
alors je comprends tout à fait qu'il
faille sauver l'économie mais pas au
prix des vies et là encore on est dans
une désorganisation qui relève de
l'amateurisme
je pense qu'on aurait dû procéder par
étapes en fonction des secteurs
économiques essentielles en organisant
une protection en s'y prenant bien
évidemment à l'avance dans ces secteurs
clé mais là et en plus y'a rien il ya
défaut grave de pédagogie
les françaises et les français ont
l'impression que c'est les vacances que
les volets s'ouvrent les fenêtres
s'ouvrent le soleil va entrer dans les
vies et qu'on peut recommencer à les
voir les copains a trinqué à se
rencontrer
alors que le virus est là l'ennemi est
là tapie et il attend bon on aurait dû
vraiment préparé ce déconfinement avec
une une une volonté de d'informer de de
traumatiser même pour forcer les
réflexes de précaution qui n'existe pas
on le voit les gens s'imaginent que
c'est le 14 juillet le feu d'artifice en
ce n'est pas ce que dit exactement jean
castel justement qui met en garde les
français une dernière question gilbert
collard mais regardons et numéro quatre
au corps à l'institut montaigne un
proche du patronat préconise aujourd'hui
des journées de travail plus longues à
jour férié supprimé une semaine de
vacances scolaires en moins recours
accru au forfait jours dans la fonction
publique ça ce sera pour après pour
rattraper les pertes économiques votre
réaction
mais je propose une diminution des
bénéfices du cac 40 des grandes
entreprises des compagnies d'assurance
des banques
il n'y a aucune raison
que ce soit le citoyen ordinaire qui
après avoir servi d'otages de cobayes
viennent faire faire faire l'esclave
financier de la situation mais c'est
trop facile
c'est vraiment absolument inacceptable
merci gilbert collard rappelle que vous
êtes député européen rassemblement
national merci d'avoir été en direct
avec nous et parmi les éléments attendus
du déconfinement la reprise des cultes
la plupart des lieux religieux sont
restés clos où le savez pendant la durée
du confinement lors d'une audio
conférence le 21 avril avec les
responsables des cultes et des
organisations laïques emmanuel macron
avait précisé que les cérémonies
religieuses
elle ne reprendraient pas avant le 2
juin mais une semaine plus tard
finalement edouard philippe a évoqué la
possibilité de reprendre sans conditions
le culte public dès le 29 mai écoutez je
sais notamment que la période du 29 mai
au 1er juin correspond pour plusieurs
cultes à des fêtes ou à des étapes
importantes du calendrier religieux
c'est pourquoi si la situation sanitaire
ne se dégrade pas au cours des premières
semaines de lever du confinement
le gouvernement est prêt à étudier la
possibilité que les offices religieux
puisse reprendre à partir du 29 mai au
lac édouard philippe qui s'exprime et le
28 avril le 29 mai donc une date qui ne
convient pas à tout le monde les
responsables musulmans notamment
s'estimerait discriminer si les
cérémonies religieuses reprenait à cette
date une date qui ne permettrait pas à
la communauté de célébrer l'une des
principales fêtes qui commémore l
appoint du mois de jeûne du ramadan
alors qu'elle permettrait aux
catholiques et aux juifs de fêter
l'ascension la pentecôte et chats vote
le recteur de la mosquée de paris se dit
prêt à saisir la justice alors est ce
légitime et religion dans leur ensemble
doivent-elles interférer dans les
décisions du gouvernement dans un pays
laïc
c'est l'objet un autre face à face
[Musique]
et pour en parler avec moi en direct
chems eddine hafiz nouveau recteur de la
grande mosquée de paris bonsoir monsieur
merci d'être avec nous à ses côtés
georges kuzmanovic président de la
république souveraine bonsoir georges
kuzmanovic merci d'être avec nous
également alors chems eddine hafiz vous
êtes l'inde et l'une des fers de lance
de ce combat vous avez eu des mots assez
durs dans votre communiqué vous demander
instamment aux pouvoirs publics que la
réouverture donc des cultes soit avancée
au 24 mai son pêne d'user de tous les
moyens légaux pour vous est-ce que
c'était un temps approprié
bonsoir d'abord oui c'était le ton
approprié parce que depuis le début de
cette pandémie en france les musulmans
de france se sont alignés aux décisions
politiques et sanitaires qui ont été
prononcées par par les autorités et à ce
titre là les musulmans de france se sont
consacrés d'abord en tant que citoyens à
vivre dans le confinement à l'instar de
tous les citoyens français et au moment
de du début du ramadan
lorsque moi j'avais entendu le président
de la république parler du 2 juin
j'avais annoncé aux fidèles musulmans
que durant le mois du ramadan il y
allait avoir deux événements importants
qui se pratique d'habitude c'est laid ce
qu'on appelle les prières surérogatoires
taraweeh après la rupture du jeûne et
pendant la soirée la récitation du coran
des ran imams et la prière collective du
vendredi et j'avais annoncé qu'en tout
état de cause le 23 ou le 24 mai date de
la fin du jeûne du ramadan
il n'y aurait pas de cris hier de l'aïd
et moi à titre personnel j'avais indiqué
que la grande mosquée de paris et les
mosquées qui
sont attachés à la grande mosquée de
paris il y en a à peu près 250 noeuds ne
rouvre ne n'ouvriraient pas leurs portes
d'ici le mois de septembre compte tenu
de la situation extrêmement complexe
mais j'ai été extrêmement surpris
lorsque j'ai appris que le premier
ministre
songez à permettre à compter du 29 mai
donc de laisser à l'intérieur de
certains lieux de culte célébré les les
fêtes
donc comme vous avez dit de pondre
conduit v de pentecôte catholique et
protestante
moi j'ai sursauté en disant mais comment
se fait-il que à ce titre là le premier
ministre oublie quand même une
composante de la société française qui
sont les musulmans mais bien évidemment
il n'est pas question d'ouvrir les lieux
de culte pour les ouvrir il faut ouvrir
un lieu de culte lorsqu'on est
pratiquement certain de pouvoir
respecter scrupuleusement les règles de
distanciation sociale et de gestes
barrières
moi personnellement en tant que recteur
de la grande mosquée de paris celle dont
qui est au 5e arrondissement de paris je
sais pertinemment que je ne pourrais pas
ouvrir parce qu'il faut savoir on y
reviendra excusez-moi chems eddine hafiz
évidemment on va y revenir justement sur
ces mesures de sécurité mais j'aimerais
quand même fait réagir georges
kuzmanovic
on a écouté l'explication est ce que
vous comprenez cela georges qu'on
semaine au beach la colère effectivement
de chems eddine hafiz
alors si nous étions dans un contexte
normal je m'opposerai au fait qu'un
représentant de culte veuille imposer
une date ou une réouverture des de ces
lieux de culte en fonction des besoins
de sa religion de tels doite dates
doivent être déterminées par la raison
et donc par des considérations
sanitaires et logistique ça tombe sous
le sens mais dans le cas précis d'une
certaine manière je comprends la
position de monsieur reprise car nous
sommes dans une situation quand même
très particulière donc ça tout le monde
voit bien que ce gouvernement gère d'une
manière
catastrophique cette crise du coït 19 on
va pas revenir sur tout sur tout les
problèmes mais juste les dates on sait
maintenant que la date de déconfinement
a été choisie d'une manière assez
hasardeuse que le premier ministre
lui-même n'avait pas l'air informé 15
minutes avant l'annoncé que ce serait le
11 mai
on sait également comme vous l'avez dit
que monsieur le président de la
république française monsieur macron a
initié des visioconférences avec et les
cultes donc il en discussion avec les
cultes donc j'imagine monsieur la fise
est que chacun a dû faire la remarque
d'un correspondant aux besoins de sa
religion
donc il est tout à fait étonnant de se
retrouver dans une situation où à
nouveau sur un terrain plat où il est
donc aucune nécessité ce gouvernement
crée un problème entre différentes
groupes religieux dans notre société
en annonçant un jour une date et
pourquoi pas le 2 juin 6 et 6 essence
est quand même en solitaire pour vous le
gouvernement a cédé aux pressions
notamment des catholiques qui ne s'en
sont pas cachés qui souhaitait au moins
la réouverture pour les fêtes de
pentecôte pour vous clairement ça a été
ce qui a expliqué cette différence entre
le 2 juin et le 29 mai non je considère
surtout que ce gouvernement ne gouverne
pas et étaient capables de prendre des
décisions sur des considérations
purement un raisonnable que sur celle
des questions sanitaires
je tiens également par contre a critiqué
la démarche initiée par monsieur
matheron c'est visioconférence avec les
cultes qui peuvent se comprendre dans un
contexte de crises et de graves
problèmes pour les familles de mener
lors des fins à la tombe et que comment
organiser les cérémonies funéraires
mais nous avons appris que cette que ces
réunions allait perdurer et que monsieur
macron qui est censé être le garant des
valeurs de la république
article 1 est temps que la république
française et sociale et laïque veut en
faire une sorte de conseil
pour aider à la cohésion du pays et se
donner les moyens de rebondir en sortie
de crise dans ce qu'il appelle sa
nouvelle société
c'est tout à fait ahurissant des les
religions mènent leur vie
l endroit de fer sont protégés par la
laïcité
on voit là la dérive anti laïque du
président de la république qui mais
c'est une continuité c'est pas quelque
chose qui me qui est née là il l'avait
déjà dit face aux évêques au collège des
bernardins lorsqu'il avait dit nous
souhaitons renouer le lien rompu avec
l'église mais sans comprendre que
justement le lien a été rompu en 1905 et
que l'idée n'est pas de le renouer
spécifiquement avec une religion
particulière et ce justement pardonnez
moi cette visioconférence avec tous les
responsables du culte on a bien compris
ce qui vous trouble et vous voilà vous
et vous estimez ne riez discriminés il
n'empêche ces religions qui font
pression le président qui discute
est ce que les religions ne sont pas un
petit peu trop puissante devant
justement comme l'a dit et georges
kauffmann dovish dans un pays tout
simplement laïque où on ne devrait pas
avoir à faire état de ce genre de
situation finalement ce que vous
comprenez ces critiques
moi je comprends ces critiques mais il
ya quelques nuances à apporter d'abord
la laïcité n'interdit pas de d'être en
relation avec les religions il y as je
vous rappelle au ministère de
l'intérieur un bureau central des cultes
qui est chargée notamment d'avoir des
relations et des liens avec les
différents responsables des cultes
moi ce que je veux dire dans cette
affaire alors je cherche ni à imposer
quoi que ce soit
moi je réagis en tant que citoyen moi ce
que je voudrais qu'on comprenne
aujourd'hui ma démarche c'est le citoyen
qui d'abord s'exprime à travers la
déclaration faite par le premier
ministre moi je suis avocat de formation
j'ai pour principe l'equilibre de 2,2
des citoyens devant la loi y ait une
égalité il y à une égalité des citoyens
devant la loi quelle que soit notre
statut que nous soyons religieux ou pas
que nous soyons femmes hommes que nous
soyons noir ou blanc il y à un principe
aujourd'hui qui fait le contrat social
français c'est que nous sommes tous
égaux et il n'y a pas de différence du
fait d'un élément qui peut
éventuellement nous disent nous
différencier par rapport aux autres
consignes à me dire clairement combien
qu'on comprenne vous sentez tout
simplement lésés par rapport aux
communautés juives et catholiques qui
pourrait affecter leur fait à la fin du
mois de mai tout simplement c'est là ça
le fond du problème si on vous suit bien
mais bien sûr et c'est à vous de me le
dire comment expliquer scientifiquement
il est assez fière non b
scientifiquement aujourd'hui nous savons
que nous vivons une grave crise
sanitaire et je partage le point de vue
de l'autre intervenant qui effectivement
montre l'amateurisme des hommes
politiques qui aujourd'hui gouverne la
france aujourd'hui ce qui est important
pour moi c'est que je voudrais
comprendre que le président pourquoi le
président maquereau a fixé le 2 juin il
y à peine une dizaine de jours pour
permettre au culte de célébrer à
l'intérieur des églises des synagogues
des temples et des mosquées leur leur
propre fait
comment se fait-il que par hasard le 2
juin était avancé au 29 mai alors moi je
lève la main en disant attention il y a
quand même une communauté musulmane qui
n'a rien demandé c'est certain qu'il
fera tout pour éviter la probable la
propagation du coc u19 à travers ces
mosquées mais en tout état de cause
expliquez moi il y a une différence à
peine de quatre jours du 24 au 29 mai
pourquoi le vous pensez que le 28 mai à
minuit à ce moment là il n'y aura plus
de coronavirus nous sommes soient en
état de guerre
soit il peut y avoir à un moment ou un
autre des idées système dérogatoire
c'est à dire même face à la guerre il y
à un système dérape
rogatoire qui complètement insupportable
je vous rappelle que le pape lui même
n'était pas du tout satisfait par la
démarche qui a été fait par les évêques
français donc aujourd'hui raison garder
moi je je je réagis simplement comme
citoyen et jacques et je suis tout à
fait d'accord pour que le religieux
reste à sa place en france il ya eu
suffisamment de souffrance dans ce pays
pour on est arrivé à la loi de 1905
vous ne verrez jamais en tout cas de ma
bouche demander des dérogations et deux
mois et donner des coups de canif à la
laïcité pour moi je considère que la
laïcité est un trésor commun que nous
devons tous préservés et vous citoyen
pardonnez moi cette mode f1 porter l
affaire devant les tribunaux si ça
devait rester en l'état c'est bien cela
absolument sur le principe du de
l'equilibre de de l'égalité entre
citoyens qui est pour moi très cher à
mes yeux
le mot de la fin rapidement george
kaufmann dovic encore une fois les
démarches de monsieur hafiz me semble
sensé dans le contexte ubuesque dans
laquelle nous placent à nouveau le
gouvernement n'avait pas besoin de ça il
annonce une date
quand on prend une décision si qu'il a
choisi de juin le choisit le 2 juin
monsieur hafiz il me semble n'a pas fait
une démarche par rapport aux deux
joueurs il aurait pu peut-être avec
l'ensemble des cultes deer ab non nous
c'est le 24 et de ses 29 est ce que ne
pouvait pas avancer d'une semaine ce
serait sympathique et le gouvernement
aurait pu répondre non messieurs nous
avons choisi le 2
parce que sanitairement c'est le 2e est
que nous avons besoin de salut de mettre
en place des effectifs
or c'est pas ça qui s'est passé donc a
priori on peut supposer que dans son
désir de renouer des relations avec les
cultes
c est peut-être que monsieur maquereau a
subi une pression monsieur philippe
puisqu'il ne se parle pas exactement on
n'a pas l'air d'opéra de se parler moi
en ce moment
et voilà ils ont décidé bon va falloir
qu'on va faire le 29 en créant un
problème communautariste qui n'allait
qui n'avait pas lieu d'être
qui sort de nulle part par leur propre
incompétence opération dans ce
chargement des vies en tout cas puisque
c'est normal
dans ce contexte là c'est légitime merci
en tout cas à tous les deux chems eddine
hafiz et georges kauffmann hobbit avoir
été avec nous en direct reste avec nous
dans quelques instants dans trois
minutes précisément direction
l'allemagne où le déconfinement est en
marche bien en marche même les écoles et
commerces ou réouvre mais après la crise
du coronavirus la justice allemande ne
remette en cause l'aide financière de la
banque centrale européenne
nous irons ensuite en russie qui devient
le cinquième pays d'europe le plus
touché par le commis 19 après avoir
recensé plus de dix mille nouveaux cas
en 24 heures
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour des tâches
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
depuis le début de cette crise les
français sont sont dans le flou avec des
informations contradictoires
quelles en sont les conséquences
psychologiquement la peur quand même
socio économique c'est à dire qu'il ya
quand même une détresse socio économique
très très fort notamment pour pour les
actifs bien évidemment plus vous êtes
âgé plus vous avez peur du réel de la
mort c'est évident les études elle
montre que oui pourquoi 30 à 40%
il y à un stress modéré il ya un stress
sévère pour à peu près 5%
on a un focus assez fort sur les
adolescents étonnamment un focus sur les
aînés également très important c'est à
dire que ceux qui résisteront le mieux
ce sont entre guillemets la classe d
actifs
est-ce que selon vous l'être humain peut
gérer une proximité quotidienne avec sa
famille comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui
est-ce que ça resserre les liens ou au
contraire est-ce que ça les haltères
nous devons réapprendre le goût du
comportement collectif voilà le goût un
peu d' une autodiscipline le goût du
civisme parce que si nous vivons ça
simplement comme une restriction de nos
libertés individuelles comme si nous ne
vivons pas ça comme une aventure
collective de protection solidaire
d1 a été jeune ça va être la
extraordinairement durs
[Musique]
très bon soir merci nous rejoindre en
direct sur rt france 20h30 heure
française cette deuxième partie
d'émission largement consacrée à la
crise du coronavirus en france et dans
le monde
l'allemagne va accélérer son
déconfinement sous la pression de
l'opinion du monde économique et des
régions un projet d'accord entre angela
merkel et les présidents de région a été
formellement adopté aujourd'hui le texte
lève la quasi-totalité des restrictions
dans le pays
les précisions avec l âme et medjahed et
cyrielle benavides bullion le projet
d'accord prévoit tout d'abord la
réouverture de toutes les écoles y
compris primaire à partir de la semaine
prochaine
toutes les écoles mais aussi les jardins
d'enfants
certaines conditions tout de même il
faut pouvoir garantir les mesures
d'hygiène et de distanciation social
dans le secondaire l'allemagne avait
déjà autorisé la réouverture
enfin pour les universités le
gouvernement laisse aux différents états
régionaux le soin de décider
autre restriction levée celles imposées
au magasin toutes les boutiques pourront
reprendre leurs activités dans les
prochains jours les propriétaires
devront bien sûr respecter les
conditions d'hygiène et contrôler les
entrées pour éviter les files d'attentes
en revanche pour la réouverture des
restaurants cafés bars et hôtels
le document laisse le champ libre aux 16
régions allemandes
les ministres régionaux de l'économie se
sont d'ailleurs mis d'accord pour
autoriser la reprise du secteur de la
gastronomie
dès ce samedi comme nous avons plusieurs
magasins c'était un temps très
difficiles un temps très dur
financièrement mais aussi vis-à-vis des
salariés
nous ne savions pas si ça allait
continuer oui ou non mais nous étions
très heureux quand nous avons eu
l'information de pouvoir ouvrir le
déconfinement peut fonctionner avec un
masque et une distance absolument
mais malheureusement pas tous nous et
s'y tient surtout dans les magasins
c'est très serré on est bousculé sur le
plan culturel l'accord prévoit de
laisser également aux régions le soin de
décider pour les théâtres salles de
concerts clubs et discothèques
côté sport les amateurs de football
peuvent être rassurés angela merkel a
accordé la reprise des matches en 1re et
2e divisions des l'animé nous avons
ensuite abordé toute une série d'autres
domaines y compris celui du commerce qui
d'une manière ou d'une autre est
maintenant rouvert sans limite
mais bien sûr avec les règles d'hygiène
à cela s'ajoute le thème des sports de
loisirs et de la bundesliga de football
qui à partir de la deuxième quinzaine de
mai sont autorisés à reprendre selon des
règles qui sont testés et approuvés
mais le projet d'accord précise bien que
cette reprise des compétitions devra
être précédée d'une quarantaine de deux
semaines pour les équipes
la ligue allemande de football plaide
depuis longtemps pour cette reprise
vital pour la survie économique d'un
secteur qui emploie en allemagne
cinquante six mille personnes
enfin des mesures de confinement sont
prévues en cas de reprise de l'épidémie
est laissée à la décision des cantons et
des villes bien que le pays se soient
d'ores et déjà félicité de chiffres
d'infection très satisfaisant
prêt pour en parler nous sommes en
direct avec toute blanche maison expert
en relations internationales bonsoir
claude blanchemaison merci d'être avec
nous par téléphone ce qu'on ait eu un
petit problème de technique on ne pourra
pas vous voir en chair et en os ce soir
comme blanchemaison quelles sont
concrètement les principales mesures que
angela merkel a annoncé aujourd'hui que
faut-il en retenir
ben moi je pense que la chancelière
angela merkel gère avec une une assez
grande habilité
cette crise du corps un virus elle l'a
montré encore cet après-midi dans sa
conférence de presse
après avoir discuté avec les 16
ministres présidents des différents
länder
madame merkel dans le son est une
scientifique donc ella ella comme vous
le savez un doctorat en physique chimie
de l'académie des sciences de berlin
s'est elle résonne de façon tout à fait
rationnel
je crois que ça rassure les allemands et
c'est probablement l'une des raisons
pour lesquelles elle a un taux de
confiance très élevé actuellement dans
la population allemande autrement dit
elle et elle est crédible alors
aujourd'hui elle a fait des compromis
parce que le le le secteur de la santé
en réalité de la compétence des régions
et länder et donc elle et elle essaie
d'harmoniser les positions prises par
des länder mais ils y arrivent jusqu'à
un certain point
donc elle a annoncé bien sûr la reprise
de la coupe de football d'allemagne ce
qui est évidemment très populaire elle a
annoncé également que tous les commerces
pourraient reprendre
et puis pour le reste c'est un petit peu
laissée au choix des différents
ministres présidents des différents
länder et elle a aussi évidemment
insisté sur les bons résultats donnés
par la façon dont la dent la l'épidémie
a été géré puisque dans le fond il ya eu
sept mille moeurs bien sûr c'est roubaix
c'est beaucoup moins que dans les autres
grands pays européens voisins alors
clairement que la gauche maison est ce
que on peut estimer qu'un gala merkel
est sous la pression des milieux
d'affaires qui voulaient faire repartir
l'économie allemande au plus vite
oui je crois qu'elle est sous la
pression bien sûr des milieux d'affaires
mais aussi de l'opinion publique
allemande est aussi des länder qui
veulent absolument en effet reprendre
l'activité est d'ailleurs le puissant
ministre conseiller de bavière lui avait
un petit peu coupé l'herbe sous le pied
en zone conférence de presse d'hier
s'appelle marcus slaughter c'est
quelqu'un de videmment très important
puisque il est le patron de la csu allié
de madame merkel et hier il a dit que
les restaurants allait rouvrir en
bavière le 25 mai et les hôtels le 30
mai donc il n'a pas attendu la
conférence aujourd'hui pour le faire le
ministre-président du mecklembourg
poméranie a également dit que les mêmes
les plages sur la baltique serait
ouverte au public à la fin du mois donc
elle préside un système d'une grande
complexité
et finalement elle le fait avec avec
beaucoup de doigté et je crois que la
population allemand de lui en sais gré
est ce que on peut dire qu'il ya une
particularité dans la gestion de la
crise du coronavirus en allemagne par
rapport aux autres pays
bah oui il ya d'abord le fait que très
tôt on a détecté le le début de
l'épidémie et que dès qu'on l'a détecté
on a mis en place un système de test et
un système de confinement et d'isolement
d'ailleurs elle s'est mise d'accord très
très rapidement avec les régions sur ce
qu'on a appelé la méthode des 3i
identifié isolé informé mais très tôt on
a on a identifié les cas avec les tests
on a isolé les gens qui étaient qu'ils
étaient infectés
et puis on a informé la population de
façon très très suivi sur ce qui se
passait et je crois que cette méthode
dans les faits à sanctionner était assez
efficace bien sûr les allemands sont
disciplinés ils ont respecté les
confinements qui leur étaient demandées
et on voit un résultat qui est qui dans
le fond est assez bon alors je pense
aussi que de l'autre l'autre élément
caractéristique c'est évidemment que le
fait d'en faire un pays fédéral et que
ces sacs états fédérés qui fournit le
budget des hôpitaux et qui finance les
hôpitaux qui par contre
dans les équipes il ya donc une saine
concurrence entre ces hôpitaux des
différentes régions et chacun ayant à
coeur naturellement d'avoir le système
de santé le plus le plus performant et
donc on en a on a vu que le nombre de
lui qui était de 28 me l'aurait en
réanimation est passé passe actuellement
à 40 milles dont trente mille avec
l'aspirateur qui fait je crois huit lits
pour 1000 habitants
c'est un record en europe donc un
système de santé il fonctionne sur la
base de la décentralisation de manière
très efficace
merci beaucoup claude blanchemaison
expert en relations internationales est
toujours en allemagne la justice
allemande remettent en cause l'aide
financière de la banque centrale
européenne
la cour constitutionnelle de karlsruhe
l'équivalent en quelque sorte de notre
conseil constitutionnel a sommé la bce
de justifier les plans de soutien
qu'elle a mis en oeuvre au profit des
pays de la zone euro l'institution
européenne doit donc sous trois mois
expliqué son action est prouvé qu'elles
étaient bien adaptées à la conjoncture
et côté le ministre allemand des
finances
la cour constitutionnelle a clairement
statué que le programme de rachats
d'obligations souveraines de la banque
centrale européenne ne constitue pas un
financement monétaire des états le
programme est donc conforme à la
constitution allemande à cet égard la
cour constitutionnelle a aussi
clairement fait savoir que pour un tel
programme
la proportionnalité doit être examiné et
a pour seul a octroyé une période de
temps assez longue de trois mois cela
signifie aussi que pour l'instant la
banque centrale allemande peut continuer
à participer au programme de rachats
commun
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
avec david capitons professeur de droit
public à l'université paris ix un
président de l'université franco
allemande mme allemande un bon soir
david capitaux merci d'être avec nous
alors c'est un sujet un petit peu
technique on va tâcher d'y voir plus
clair avec vous déjà pourquoi la justice
allemande remettent en cause l'aide
financière de la bce
effectivement la première question vous
avez raison c'est de s'interroger sur le
fait savoir dans quelle mesure une
juridiction allemande peut contrôler les
décisions qui sont prises par une
institution européenne alors c'est
évidemment un peu un tour de passe-passe
auxquels procède la cour
constitutionnelle fédérale allemande
elle ne peut pas être directement
contrôlé la décision la banque centrale
européenne qui n'est pas soumise à la
constitution allemande
en revanche ce qu'elle contrôle c'est
l'action du gouvernement allemand et du
parlement allemand l'allemagne en tant
qu'etat membre de l'union européenne
évidemment participe aux décisions qui
sont prises au niveau européen notamment
parce que au sein des institutions
européennes et en tant qu'etat membre et
bien elle peut contrôler les décisions
qui sont prises par une autre
institution européenne qu'est la banque
centrale européenne est ce que la cour
constitutionnelle allemande a mis en
cause
eh bien c'est la carence de l'état
allemand dans le contrôle qu'il a
exercée sur les décisions prises par la
banque centrale européenne
l'idée qu'ils étaient sous jacente alors
elle est un petit peu double d'une part
cette ce cette décision la cour
allemande s'inscrit dans une série de
décisions qui sont rendus depuis
plusieurs dizaines d'années dans
lesquelles la cour constitutionnelle
fédérale allemande essaye de mettre en
place une espèce de tension à une
tension bienveillante sans doute mais
une tension qui permet qu'un contrôle de
l'un sur l'autre s'exerce entre les
institutions l'union européenne qui
évidemment imposent leurs décisions et
amant mais également les états membres
sur lesquels reposent l'union européenne
et donc la cour considère qu'en tant que
cour nationale
il lui appartient avec la cour
européenne de contrôler le respect des
traités européens par les institutions
européennes elles soient concrètes
pardonnez moi de vous couper l'arrière
pensée si j'ose dire c'est de remettre
en cause la primauté du droit européen
sur le droit national
alors ça n'est pas de la remettre en
cause parce qu'en effet dans cette
décision un cour constitutionnelle
fédérale allemande e rang de grand
hommage à la cour de justice de l'union
européenne et considère qu'il est normal
que les cours nationales respecte et
s'incline devant les décisions qui sont
prises au niveau de la cour de
luxembourg donc de la cour de justice de
l'union européenne
mais en même temps rappelle la cour ce
respect qu en tant que juridiction
allemande et comme les juridictions
françaises italiennes ou espagnoles nous
devons avoir pour les décisions de la
cour de luxembourg et qui repose sur le
principe de primauté du droit européen
suppose en même temps que la cour de
justice de l'union européenne elle-même
rendent des décisions qui soient
compréhensibles qui repose sur
l'utilisation de principes notamment
d'interprétation des traités européens
qui sont conformes aux techniques
d'interprétation du droit qui ont cours
dans la tradition commune aux
juridictions européennes et en
l'occurrence la cour allemande écarte
une décision qui a été rendue par la
cour de justice de l'union européenne
sur la question du rachat de dette
publique donc d' actifs souverains en
considérant que la cour de justice de
l'union européenne qui était amené à
contrôler elle même les décisions de la
banque centrale européenne n'a pas
exercé un contrôle suffisamment complet
pour qu'elle puisse considérer la
décision rendue par la cour d'assisses
salal une compétence cd droit
effectivement et c'est important comme
le fond du problème
de quoi l'allemagne at elle peur au fond
qu'on lui fasse les poches c'est ça le
le fond du problème clairement il ya un
double fond du problème si vous
permettez d'ajouter malgré tout un
élément de complexité dans tout ça
d'abord il faut se rendre compte que
l'allemagne est un pays fédéral et que
comme un pays fédéral elle a l'habitude
de traiter des questions de répartition
des compétences entre les länder qui la
composent et la fédération et que bien
entendu ce souci qui qui qui qui nourrit
qui s'appuie sur sa structure eh bien
elle la projette sur l'union européenne
elle est donc particulièrement sensible
à la question de la répartition des
compétences entre les états membres
et l'union européenne de manière
générale c'est un souci qui peut
paraître un peu exotique pour des
français nous qui sommes habitués à un
état centralisé qui fonctionne de
manière très hiérarchique où tout part
du sommet consent félicitons le déplore
mais c'est comme ça que nous
fonctionnons les allemands refonctionne
plutôt sur des contrats sont des accords
entre différents niveaux et donc ils
transposent simplement dans leur regard
sur l'union européenne
le regard qu'ils ont l'habitude de
porter sur eux mêmes dans leur
fonctionne donc ça c'est un premier
élément d'arrière-plan le deuxième
élément en l'occurrence est
effectivement qu'il s'agit de la
politique de la banque centrale
européenne que la banque centrale
européenne d'après les traités européens
sa compétence et elle est clairement
défini notamment par le traité sur le
fonctionnement de l'union européenne
consiste à s'occuper de politique
monétaire et surtout à ne pas s'occuper
de politique économique ou de politique
budgétaire il ya une différence
clairement établies entre les deux et on
se rappelle d'ailleurs que quand lampe
banque centrale européenne a été mise en
place
et bien c'est le modèle de la bundesbank
allemande qui a été repris c'est à dire
une banque centrale qui ne doit pas
comme la banque américaine à intervenir
à la demande de l'exécutif pour
faciliter le la politique budgétaire
nationale au contraire doit se
concentrer sur la politique monétaire
or en l'occurrence le foeil la banque
centrale européenne quand elle rachète
des dettes souveraines
certes elle fait la politique monétaire
parce que ce faisant elle permet de
créer de la monnaie et donc qu'on espère
grâce à ça qu'on va faire un peu
remonter l'inflation parce que tout le
monde voyait l'inflation autour de 2%
or pour l'instant une à une inflation
qui est beaucoup plus bas ce qui n'est
pas sain sans doute au plan économique
donc ça c'est bien la politique
monétaire et personne ne leur reproche
cependant en rachetant de la dette
publique
et bien non seulement on crée de la
monnaie mais en même temps évidemment
facilite la création de dettes par les
états membres
et ça évidemment l'allemagne qui est
elle très stable et très vertueuse dans
ses finances publiques
et bien ne peut pas admettre qu à côté
d'elle il y ait d'autres états au
contraire qui est des dépenses beaucoup
plus importante que leurs revenus et
comme vous le dites elle a un peu
l'impression que l'on s'appuie sur la
stabilité financière de l'allemagne pour
faciliter l'émission de dette par des
pays qui sinon et bien devrait emprunter
de l'argent à des taux beaucoup plus
important qu'il ne peuvent le faire
grâce à cette politique
et donc c'est ça que critique la course
et ce mélange des genres c'est qu'en
prétendant faire de la politique
monétaire
en réalité la banque centrale européenne
fait de la politique budgétaire
mais ça c'est contraire aux traités et
l'allemagne très appuyé sur la question
la répartition des compétences ne veut
pas l'admettre remercie beaucoup david
capy temps d'avoir été avec nous en
italie à présent le bilan du coronavirus
repart à la hausse le pays enregistre
369 morts de plus ces dernières 24
heures soit 133 de plus que l'éveil au
total litanie troisième pays le plus
touché après les états unis et le
royaume uni pour la mortalité déplore
près de 30000 morts nombre de nouveaux
cas également augmenté il est passé de
1075 mardi à 1444 mercredi et la russie
devient le cinquième pays d'europe le
plus touché par la crise après avoir
recensé plus de dix mille nouveaux car
en 24 heures après le premier ministre
mir est la miche austin et le ministre
de la construction on appris la
contamination de la ministre de la
culture ces derniers jours le kobe 19
connaît une propagation très rapide pour
autant la russie affiche l'un des taux
de mortalité les plus faibles d'europe
avec un peu moins de 166 mille cas et
1451 décès les autorités russes
affirment que cela est dû à la fermeture
rapide des frontières au grand nombre de
tests effectués et au suivi de
l'infection chez les personnes
contaminées et les précisions sur place
à moscou de notre reporter antoine
gayraud levier poutine a bien parlé de
déconfinement mais avec beaucoup de
prudence et ce pour plusieurs raisons
parle de l'avis des experts le pic de la
pandémie n'est pas encore atteint en
effet pour le quatrième jour consécutif
plus de dix mille nouveaux cas ont été
recensés ces dernières 24 heures et même
si la situation tend à se stabiliser
elle reste fragile et d'autre part cette
situation n'est pas uniforme dans tout
le pays et varie beaucoup en fonction de
région je vous propose d'écouter
vladimir poutine
nous voyons que la situation autour de
la propagation du coronavirus varie
selon les régions de la fédération de
russie
comme je les ai déjà dit dans certaines
régions il est nécessaire de maintenir
des mesures strictes mais justifiée ou
même de les renforcer
alors que dans d'autres régions il
faudrait envisager de les assouplir de
manière rationnelle et uniquement en
s'appuyant sur l'avis des chercheurs des
spécialistes et compte tenu de tous les
facteurs et de tous les risques
je le souligne encore une fois il ne
faut pas s'emballer toute imprudence ou
précipitations peuvent mener à un échec
un recul le prix de la moindre erreur
est la sécurité la vie la santé de nos
concitoyens
c'est pourquoi pour chaque décision nos
collègues du gouvernement et les
dirigeants des régions en dos une très
grande responsabilité alors dans le
détail des recommandations ont été
émises par l'autorité de santé publique
à destination des gouverneurs de régions
responsables de cette organisation à
l'impôt va expliquer que le
déconfinement se ferait progressivement
en trois étapes en trois paliers bien
distincts écouté les recommandations
concernant la levée des mesures de
restriction que nous avons rédigé
constitue un outil méthodologique précis
destiné à ce travail nous proposons de
procéder en trois phases la première
phase prévoit l'autorisation des
activités physiques et du sport en
extérieur des promenades avec des
enfants du fonctionnement des
entreprises commerciales et du secteur
tertiaire d'une surface ne dépassant pas
certaines limites
avec respect de la distanciation sociale
la deuxième phase prévoit l'autorisation
des promenades à l'extérieur avec la
famille du fonctionnement des
entreprises commerciales et du secteur
tertiaire d'une surface supérieure aux
limites susmentionnés mais avec une
limitation du nombre de clients pouvant
être présents dans un seul endroit
simultanément en outre elle prévoit la
réouverture des établissements
d'enseignement pendant la troisième
phase les zones récréatives notamment
les parcs et jardins publics seront
rouverts avec respect de la
distanciation sociale ainsi que les
entreprises commerciales et du secteur
tertiaire tous les établissements
d'enseignement les hôtels et les
services de restauration à moscou
l'encontre
de la moitié des personnes infectées le
déconfinement n'est pas encore
d'actualité
seuls les salariés des secteurs de
l'industrie et de la construction vont
pouvoir reprendre le travail à partir du
12 mai ce qui représente malgré tout un
demi million de personnes
par contre le sujet de la réouverture
des frontières n'a pas encore été
évoquée et là encore la prudence est de
mise
la compagnie aérienne nationale aeroflot
par exemple n'envisage pas pour le
moment de reprendre ses vols
internationaux avant le milieu de l'été
mais quand pau le chef de la diplomatie
américaine s'est exprimé une nouvelle
fois à propos de l'origine du
coronavirus pour lui il ya je suis des
preuves significatives mais pas de
certitude que le virus proviennent du
laboratoire de one hand dimanche le chef
le secrétaire d'état américain sur la
chaîne nbc avait déjà tenu des propos
similaires en regrettant le manque de
coopération chinoise puis jeudi dernier
dans un train avait déjà lié le nouveau
coronavirus à l'institut de virologie de
one le président américain avait menacé
la chine de taxes punitives
l'ambassadeur chinois aux états unis a
répondu clairement ces affirmations sont
fausses
si le président américain ou le
secrétaire d'état michael p e ont des
preuves qu'il n'hésite pas à les montrer
au monde entier
si vous avez des preuves tangibles que
cela vient d'un laboratoire de wuhan
vous devez montrer ses preuves au monde
entier plutôt que de pointer du doigt
avec des accusations sans fondement et
dans la foulée mais mon père a tenu à
rappeler que la chine détenait toujours
des informations décisives concernant le
patient zéro des informations cruciales
pour l'avancée des recherches sur le
virus selon le secrétaire d'état
les chinois disent vouloir coopérer
génial coopérer c'est agir c'est
s'ouvrir c'est partager ses informations
les détails de l'endroit où le patient
zéro a été identifiées sont des choses
qui ne sont connus que par le parti
communiste chinois
c'est lui qui peut aider à débloquer la
situation en demandant de l'aide
nous serions heureux de leur fournir
cette aide nous avons besoin le monde a
besoin de réponses à ces questions pas
seulement dans la situation actuelle
mais aussi pour éviter qu'une telle
situation se reproduise avec des
milliers et des milliers de vies perdues
et un désastre économique dont le monde
entier est toujours aux états unis pour
endiguer l'épidémie certaines villes
comme san francisco ont mis à la
disposition des sans abri des logements
d'urgence
conséquence les autorités doivent faire
face à un arrivage massif david khalifa
avec valentin carpentier à chaque coin
de rue ou presque les mêmes images san
francisco doit faire face à un afflux
inédit de sans abri et anciens détenus
libérés pour cause de kobe 19
la cause les mesures ambitieuses prises
par la ville louée des milliers de
chambres d'hôtel vacante pour fournir un
logement d'urgence aux sans abri pendant
l'épidémie
les services des aides sont donc
débordés et ne peuvent répondre à une
demande constante venant bien souvent
d'autres régions des états unis ils
viennent ici parce qu'ils croient qu'ils
peuvent obtenir une teinte et qu'ils
peuvent entrer dans le système pour
obtenir un logement et c'est donc
vraiment un fardeau pour notre système
qui est déjà imposants conséquence de
cet afflux
les organismes de bienfaisance
alimentaires ont vu leurs distributions
de repas augmenter drastiquement
une situation qui ne s'améliore pas
malgré le déconfinement de la californie
prévu ce vendredi 5 anthony existe
depuis soixante dix ans et nous
assistons certainement un afflux de
personnes inédit utilisant nos services
avant le coup vite 19 il y avait en
moyenne environ 2300 personnes par jour
et maintenant ils nous ont envoyés aux
moyennes 3300 voire trois mille huit
cents par jour
les autorités n'avaient pas prévu un tel
arrivage de personnes dans le besoin
la californie étant l'un des états les
plus touchés par la pandémie avec plus
de cinquante mille cas confirmés et plus
de 2300 80 décès liés à la maladie près
partout sur la planète le secteur
médical était en première ligne est en
première ligne pendant cette crise
auront à 90 mille travailleurs de la
santé dans le monde auraient été
infectés par le cos vite 19
ce chiffre peut potentiellement être
multipliée par deux selon le conseil
international des infirmières
les estimations contamination sont
basées sur des informations recueillies
dans 30 pays
le conseil exhorte les autorités à tenir
des régis plus précis pour empêcher la
propagation du virus
la maladie a tué plus de 260 infirmières
précise également dans un communiqué
l'association basée à genève
le chiffre des infections des
travailleurs de la santé est passée de
23 mille à plus de 90 mille selon nous
mais cela reste une sous-estimation car
ils ne couvrent pas tous les pays du
monde
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons des annonces des manuels
micron pour aider le monde de la culture
puis depuis le début du confinement tout
est à l'arrêt un plan d'urgence a donc
été dévoilée
et puis nous évoquerons la près 11 mai
la france peut-elle craindre la violence
sociale les autorités se pose des
questions sur le plan de l'ordre public
[Musique]
vous vous dites que ce délit de
violation du confinement n'est pas
conforme à la constitution comme ceux
des votes revient à au moins deux
principes majeurs celui de légalité des
délits et des peines et le principe de
sanctions
qu'est ce qu'un achat de première
nécessité qu'est ce que j'aime une belle
impérieux j'ai finalement été laissée à
la libre appréciation de l'agent et ça
ne nous prémunit pas contre un despote
arbitral questionnaire déclaré je ne
quitte pas qu'il y ait des erreurs et
c'est parce que tu ne me dites pas qu'il
y aurait des erreurs et j'ai veillé à ce
que le délai de contestation
et c'est là où la présomption
d'innocence n'est pas respectée c'est un
problème bien sûr mais il reste on vit
tous les jours sans faire attention que
tout en dépend c'est l'unité de mesure
de toute chose une convention admise par
tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
où
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on me vois pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
alors ce qui si c'est interdit
d'interdire
[Musique]
je reçois john shipton le père de julien
assange fondateur de wikileaks est
actuellement derrière les barreaux à
londres selon les avocats du
gouvernement américain julian assange
aurait mis en danger la vie de ces
sources
saskia s'est tout simplement fait
wikileaks coopérait avec 90 autres
organes d'information pour filtrer
expurgée et analyser les câbles à 65 ans
julian et son équipe ont essayé de
prévenir le département d'état mais on
les a ignorés qu'est-ce que ça en dit
sur la liberté d'expression d'après vous
notamment dans les pays occidentaux
il n'y a pas de liberté d'expression ça
il s'agit d' intimidation et
d'oppression des journalistes un opéra
est un soin afin que le public ne
dispose pas des informations nécessaires
pour juger les systèmes dans lesquels
ils vivent
personne aucun journaliste n'est prêt à
tenir tête aux états unis après ce que
julian a subi danse
[Musique]
d
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'émission il est
21h heure de paris wassim des titres de
l'actualité de ce mercredi prolonger les
droits des intermittents jusqu'à août
2021 création d'un fonds d'indemnisation
pour les séries et tournage annulé
emmanuel macron vient en aide au monde
de la culture il a dévoilé son plan pour
sauver le secteur lourdement impacté par
la crise sanitaire
la france peut-elle craindre la violence
sociale de nombreuses interrogations
planent sur les prés 11 mai des
inquiétudes sur le plan épidémique mais
les autorités se posent également des
questions sur le plan de l'ordre public
la colère des français est toujours bien
là les revendications d'avant également
des tensions auxquelles viennent
s'ajouter la gestion de cette crise
sanitaire du gouvernement
mais tout d'abord ces chiffres le bilan
de l'épidémie du coronavirus dans
l'hexagone qui est tombée peu avant 20h
on compte 25 1809 décès au total en
france selon le dernier bilan de la
direction générale de la santé 278
personnes sont mortes en 24 heures un
chiffre en baisse le nombre de personnes
en réanimation continue lui aussi baissé
avec 283 malades en moins
du côté de la carte de département de la
sarthe passe de l'oranje aux verts
emmanuel macron au chevet de la culture
pour calmer la colère du monde des arts
et du spectacle le chef de l'état a donc
choisi de recevoir en visioconférence
douze artistes il faut dire que depuis
le début du confinement
tout est à l'arrêt le secteur est
fortement impacté par cette crise
sanitaire pour lui venir en aide un plan
d'urgence a été dévoilée on retiendra la
prolongation des droits des
intermittents jusqu'à ou 2021 ou encore
la création d'un fonds d'indemnisation
pour les séries ou les tournages annulé
autre annonce les librairies les
galeries d'art ou certains musées
devraient rouvrir leurs portes le 11 mai
à certaines conditions pour la
réouverture des théâtres un point sera
fait fin mai début juin la culture a un
rôle à part le 11 mai beaucoup de choses
vont reprendre en évitant le brassage on
va rouvrir des choses on doit pouvoir
rouvrir musée librairie galerie on doit
aussi pouvoir ouvrir les théâtres pour
que les gens puissent répéter en
respectant les consignes un les lieux de
création doivent revivre les artistes
recréer et puis on aura un point fin mai
et début juin on va regarder comment les
choses se passent un tour d'horizon en
images de ces mesures annoncées par le
chef de l'état
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
parmi les secteurs impactés celui du
cinéma les salles sont désertés elle
aussi depuis le 14 mars dernier un
manque à gagner considérable pour les
établissements alors que le gouvernement
a évoqué une possible réouverture le 2
juin reportage dans un cinéma du
quartier du 9e arrondissement de paris
julien de la cour avec pierre mazel un
an et demi qu'il n'a pas ouvert ses
portes au public
comme toutes les salles obscures de
france le cinéma de quartier les cinq
caumartin fait lui aussi les frais du
coronavirus malgré la fermeture son
directeur continue de faire tourner les
projecteurs une fois par semaine le
cinéma ça commerce qui ne ferme jamais
même le jour ne s'est pas fait pour être
éteints donc certains matériaux à
l'intérieur doit être rallumé une fois
par semaine parce que pour remettre les
horloges
numérique à l'heure et plein d'autres
choses parce que c'est vraiment pas fait
c'est pas des machines qui sont pas
faites pour être éteinte pendant un
longue période
d'ailleurs le cinéma n'a jamais été
aussi longtemps le lieu d'ordinaire si
animé désormais vidée de sa clientèle
une période très compliquée pour le
personnel en chômage partiel
malgré des aides du gouvernement
l'avenir du cinéma restent floues c'est
sûr qu'ils ont ouverte envers damas le
cinéma je pense 30% de sa capacité pour
les gestes barrières parce que je pense
que nos proches il y aura une rangée sur
deux un siège sur trois enfin un jour on
ne sait pas encore en revanche et encore
c'est des suppositions et donc c'est sûr
qu'on va démarrer avec un chiffre
d'affaires très bas donc avoir une aide
au moins du redémarrage quoi ça reste
une fête et un endroit agréable que ce
soit pas obligé et on fera mieux est
vraiment mieux pour pour les spectateurs
on a déjà commencé à commander des
masques
pour notre premier collaborateur on a
commandé des gels hydroalcooliques et on
est en train de changer toutes nos
systèmes de chasse d'eau s'est pas
beaucoup n'ont pas besoin de toucher on
a train de changer le système c'est
chemin enfin n'est vraiment en train
d'investir et sa d'investissement il
assez lourd pour une petite entreprise
comme la nôtre je le vis très très belle
enfin je parce que le cinéma est un
comme ça je n'avais jamais vu ça je suis
une famille d'exploitants
j'avais jamais vu un cinéma étant aussi
longtemps samuel mer le prend son mal en
patience en attendant le feu vert de
l'état qui doit statuer sur la
réouverture ou non des cinémas le 2 juin
prochain
ok ce secteur de la culture nous sommes
en direct avec loïc bonnet directeur du
théâtre à l'ouest de rouen fondateur de
l'association théâtre privé en région
bonsoir merci à vous d'être avec nous
loïc abonnés à ses côtés valérie aux
étonna des plus grands producteurs
musicale en france a notamment des
vieilles canailles 1 par exemple pour ne
citer qu'elles bonsoir à vous aussi
weideli zeitoun alors loïc bonne et il
ya certains de vos confrères qu'on a
entendues sur les médias cet après midi
est plutôt satisfait par ces mesures
notamment sur la question des
intermittents qui était l'une des
grandes urgences vous est ce que vous
êtes satisfait également comment voulez
vous qu'un directeur de théâtre privé
soient satisfaits des mesures qui sont
aujourd'hui annoncées c'est pas possible
même si c'est très bien pour les
intermittents c'est très bien pour les
artistes puisque la culture a besoin d
artiste a besoin d intermittent mais si
vous n'avez pas de salle pour mettre ces
artistes et intermittents
moi je représente aujourd'hui 80 salles
qui sont des théâtres privés en région
des salles qui font entre 50 et 400
places sont des sociétés privées qui ne
demande pas de subventions le reste du
temps un peu comme l'exploitant du
cinéma qu'on vient de voir le moral des
troupes est au plus bas et on l'a vu
avec ce monsieur bien sûr que ça fait
mal parce qu'on n'a aucune perspective
et parce que aujourd'hui les
perspectives qu'on allait seul peu de
perspectives pour noël sont pas bonnes
qui va venir au théâtre dans quelles
conditions tout ça en fait nous la tpr
on s'est regroupé il ya quinze jours
environ parce qu'on était tout seul dans
nos lieux y avait pas vraiment de
l'association des théâtres privés en
région le ministère savait même pas
combien en été en france aujourd'hui on
a fait leur boulot
on leur a dit bah voilà nous on s'est
regroupé on et 91
discuter avec vous pour justement
essayer de parler de reprise mais aussi
par les dead parce que très clairement
j'entendais les investissements faisait
ce cinéma mais comment voulez vous
qu'une entreprise privée qui fait zéro
euro de chiffre d'affaires depuis le 14
mars face des investissements enfin ces
voix là et je vous parle même pas de
l'état moral parce qu'on l'a vu avec cet
exploitant mais moi j'ai eu des coups de
fil tout l'après midi des adhérents des
directeurs de théâtre qui sont comme moi
des femmes et des hommes qui ont
construit leur société depuis 40 ans 30
ans 20 ans c'est théâtre là vont
disparaître très clairement nous n'avons
pas eu une seule aide encore alors il ya
des êtres qui se met en place il ya des
fonds d'urgence ont encore parlé d'une
définition de l'urgence mais aujourd'hui
on n'a pas de perspective
on attend une date et on attend surtout
des aides pour la reprise parce que
quand on va avoir 30 % de notre salle en
fréquentation comment on va vivre des
aides et après on va donner la parole à
valéry zeitoun des aides et et surtout
une date peut-être deux reprises parce
qu'on a parlé des répétitions chefs
d'état niveau là iront boire et péter
m'enfin mais il faut aider a prôné
l'élection
oui bien sûr non mais bien sûr alors les
pièges je vais vous dire elles sont
prêtes
y'a pas de problème les caisses elles
étaient prêtes avant donc elles sont
prêtes maintenant les répétitions si
vous voulez un théâtre c'est simple
c'est comme un cinéma
sauf qu'il ya des gens sur scène c'est
du spectacle vivant mais s'il n'y a pas
de public vous pouvez répéter ce que
vous voulez si vous n'avez pas de
perspective pour savoir comment vous
mettez le public qui y va y avoir dans
les salles c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
ça la préoccupation première de ces
théâtres et surtout la viabilité
économique de ce secteur
mais je vois valéry zeitoun c'est pareil
en valais le dans les concerts et les
festivals on est tous pareils on est
tous bloqués on se demande comment on va
vivre parce qu'on est des privés encore
une fois les annonces du juste le second
encore les annonces du président qui
sont très bonnes et très belle cet après
midi pour le secteur public vous savez
on dit souvent que le ministère de la
culture s'occupe vraiment beaucoup du
public mais nous on est des privés on a
besoin de vendre des billets pour vivre
tout simplement
fédérer tout de même constat notamment
pour les scènes de concerts dans le même
temps c'est vraiment compliqué d'aller
rassemblé peut-être des gens en ce
moment dans dans des salles je vous
entends pas
bien je crois que la liaison n'est pas
très bonne mais je rejoins monsieur
bonnet dans son constat je crois qu'il
ya eu plusieurs annonces dans dans
l'intervention du président de la
république qui est un littéraire avancer
parce que c'est comme ça qu'il a il a
séduit beaucoup de gens lors de la
campagne 2010 cette séquelle c'est
quelqu'un qui est très cultivé
alors la bonne nouvelle
effectivement c'est pour les
intermittents le fait que le statut
d'intermittent soit assurée jusqu'en
juin et août 2021 c'est une bonne
nouvelle maintenant moins ce que
j'essaye de retenir d'un gouvernement et
d'un état c'est combien ils donnent à la
filière pour s'en sortir
je n'ai pas beaucoup entendu de chiffres
j'ai entendu 50 millions d'euros pour le
centre national de la musique
j'ai entendu aussi des non sens le fait
qu'un président de la république dise
que nous pouvons faire répéter nos
artistes mais qu' il n'y aura pas de
public
monsieur bonnet le sais comme moi quand
on est producteur ou directeurs de
théâtre ont fait répéter des artistes
parce qu'on a une date butoir et que le
public va investir pour venir voir nos
spectacles
mais faire répéter des artistes sans
savoir quand est-ce que le spectacle va
pouvoir avoir lieu est un non sens total
et il nous rajoute à ça que au lieu
d'avoir du public dans les salles
on va faire venir des jeunes des
quartiers défavorisés pour assister aux
répétitions mais on n'est pas l'armée du
salut
on est la culture française on
représente la culture françaises privées
publiques et on est tous à la même
enseigne face à cette épidémie
mais il faut nous aider parce que ce qui
est en train d'arriver
c'est ici on regarde un peu plus loin
que ces dates
le corps en un virus et fait qu' on est
tous confinés qu' on ne peut pas faire
notre métier mais
c'est les petits qui vont trinquer parce
qu'à la sortie de cette de cette crise
les gros c'est à dire les entreprises
culturelles qui sont très puissantes je
parle d'universal de sony de toutes les
compagnies qui ont les moyens de tenir
parce que l on de du cash flow pour
tenir pendant six mois lui moi un an
ben c'est pas le cas de monsieur bonnet
et c'est pas mon cas qui nous le sommes
de vrais indépendant et qui avons besoin
que que que que nos artistes se
produisent pour gagner des sous et pour
financer nos journaux nos prochains
spectacles donc le le jeu des d'ores et
déjà est faussé et puis je suis assez
inquiet parce que nous avons un ministre
qui ya à peine trois semaines nous
proposait de faire des spectacles devant
cinquante personnes avec un seul artiste
sur scène et j'ai le sentiment que les
gens qui gèrent un peu nos métiers dans
les ministères ne sont pas du tout au
courant des us et coutumes et de ce que
coûte nous métier alors emmanuel macron
lui la table emmanuel macron lui appelle
la culture à ceux à se réinventer alors
on sait pas trop ce qui veut dire mais
c'est vrai que au japon par exemple on
sait qu'il ya des pièces de théâtre qui
sont diffusées à distance à la
télévision dans les cinémas est ce que
on pourrait envisager d'autres
possibilités en attendant des jours
meilleurs selon vous l'ong beney oui
peut-être enfin moi je trouve que c'est
un non sens qu'au total et surtout moi
je suis directeur d'un théâtre donc un
théâtre si j'ai pas de public et si je
diffusais la télé personne ne viendra
personne ne regardera j'ai pas de modèle
économique et surtout vous savez on
parle pas souvent du tissu social du
tissu dans nos régions dans ces villes
où on a des clients qui viennent rigoler
et c'est très important quand on sort
d'une dune d'une période angoissante
comme ça on n'a pas besoin de sortir on
a besoin de rigoler on est un vrai tissu
social pour nos régions
et ça il faut pas l'oublier vraiment
valéry zeitoun effectivement on n'a plus
besoin que jamais peut-être de se
divertir
de se nourrir de la culture non mais
j'ai entendu le discours du président
est quelque part ils nous demandent des
réinventer la roue alors j'ai vu qu' il
n'y a pas longtemps certains producteurs
au danemark par exemple on dit ben on va
refaire comme aux états unis dans les
années 50 vous savez quand on allait
voir les films dans la death and roll
bon très bien mais c'est pas une
solution de dire à une filière
économique vous devez vous réinventer le
spectacle ça reste une scène une salle
et des gens qui payent des billets pour
pour pour aller voir le spectacle je ne
sais pas comment on peut réinventer
nous notre modèle économique c'est à
dire qu'on a un état qui nous dit pas
essayer de vous recréez parce que on n'a
pas de date de déconfinement réel ça
n'est pas une réponse adaptée je crois
alors pour rééquilibrer je le répète moi
je suis ravi pour les intermittents et
c'est à dire tous les gens qui
travaillent avec nous au quotidien les
techniciens les maquilleurs etc etc
ça c'est la bonne réaction du du
gouvernement et de l'état mais surtout
le reste du discours je suis quand même
assez sceptique
merci en tout cas à tous les deux loïc
bonnet valéry zeitoun on rappelle qu on
en sort un petit peu plus a tout de même
on peut espérer on l'espère d'ailleurs
sur l'ouverture des scènes de concerts
des théâtres on en saura plus fin mai
début juin a promis emmanuel macron
attendant bon courage à tous les deux et
merci à vous cette crise sanitaire qui a
touché la quasi totalité des secteurs
économiques du pays les producteurs de
minéraux s'ils n'y ont pas échappé
c'est pourquoi le syndicat national des
brasseurs indépendants lance aujourd'hui
une campagne de financement participatif
en ligne depuis le début du confinement
au moins 10 millions de litres de bière
ont été détruits on le répète la bière
est à consommer avec modération solène
godin avec lionel girard sont allés à la
rencontre d'un brasseur artisanal en
normandie première bière depuis le début
du confinement
nicolas vieillard relance sa brasserie
dont l'activité a été stoppé net le 17
mars vous s'arrêter du jour au lendemain
nous on venait d'ouvrir nos bars le soir
même on est obligé de le fermer
j'avais mis carnet de commandes était
plein je vais aller livrer tous été
annulés
donc un choc le terrible ça représente
80 % de perte en chiffre d'affaires bars
et restaurants fermés concert des salles
ont annulé les plus gros clients de la
micro brasserie sont eux aussi à l'arrêt
alors pour limiter les pertes
financières l'entreprise a dû trouver
des alternatives pour vendre particulier
entre autres des achats en ligne de
bière payées maintenant met à boire dès
le confinement levées
on a de cette plateforme qui nous permet
de communiquer et d'avoir de la
trésorerie maintenant sur des bières
qu'on fabrique maintenant et qui seront
vus effectivement dans trois mois quand
elles seront disponibles
on a commencé par le drive parce
qu'effectivement ça nous permettait de
respecter vraiment les gestes barrière
un maximum pour les personnes de pouvoir
préparer les commandes en avance dans un
maximum de de propreté et d'isolement
mais les ventes restent modestes et les
aides de l'état insuffisantes pour ce
brasseur des conséquences économiques
qui pourraient avoir un impact sur les
prix
il ya eu la première règle à 2500 euros
et qui couvrent à peine
mais charge ce qui couvre même pas du
tout mes charges aujourd'hui j'étais
obligé de faire un report de ces moi mon
crédit ça me revient à 2000 euros
supplémentaires d'intérêt j'espère que
la concurrence est trop rude aussi je
sais pas comment bourse se maintenir les
prix nous petits producteurs
on peut pas réduire réduire réduire les
marges à un moment il faut aussi qu'on
vive les industriels va derrière déjà
leurs prix sont déjà très bas ils vont
ils sont beaucoup plus de moyens ils
vont inonder aussi tous les réseaux ces
inquiétudes pèsent sur l'ensemble du
secteur
la france est le pays européen qui
compte le plus de brasseurs indépendants
en tout mille huit cents artisans sont
concernés on voit bien de nombreuses
interrogations en plane sur l'après 11
mai des inquiétudes sur le plan
épidémique mais aussi en ce qui concerne
l'ordre public
les contestations sociales vont
certainement être amplifiée par cette
crise sanitaire est vite khalifa deux
mois verrouillé deux mois qui vont
marquer à jamais la france dans son
histoire mais le virage du déconfinement
risque aussi de faire beaucoup de bruit
la colère des français est toujours là
les revendications d'avant également
viennent s'ajouter à sa plusieurs
facteurs qui ne font qu'amplifier la
tension sociale à travers le pays tout
d'abord la gestion de cette crise
sanitaire entre 60 et 70% des personnes
interrogées ne font pas confiance au
gouvernement qui n'est pas à la hauteur
de la situation
les affrontements durant le confinement
autres forces de l'ordre et jeunes des
banlieues également et surtout une
prolifération des invitations lancées
sur les réseaux sociaux pour recommencer
à manifester à partir du 11 mai tous ces
éléments inquiète le ministère de
l'intérieur
le jour d'après est un thème fortement
mobilisateur des mouvance contestataire
le confinement ne permet plus à la
gronde populaire de s'exprimer mais la
colère ne faiblit pas et la gestion de
crise très critique et nourrit la
contestation
point d'orgue des critiques envers la
gestion de cette crise les masques le
port généralisé va certainement attiser
les convoitises
ce qui inquiète fortement les autorités
plusieurs régions par l'intermédiaire
des syndicats ont demandé à beyrouth de
surveillance à la police pour éviter les
cambriolages des stocks en pharmacie ou
en grande surface en première ligne
les forces de l'ordre qui craignent de
voir une m déjà présentes amplifiée par
le confinement
ces deux mois ont été longs pour
beaucoup les amendes que nous avons dû
infliger nous ont transformés en cible
le risque de virus était jusque là une
arme de dissuasion massive mais
maintenant que tout le monde a des
masques la crainte de la contamination
se dissipe et le fait de se couvrir le
visage permet de se dissimuler
de nombreux maires sont inquiets et
redoutent une détérioration progressive
du climat social jusqu'au 24 juillet
date prévue de l'expiration de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire
à savoir que le concept de jours d'après
séduit aussi les syndicats traditionnels
il estime que la crise démontre les
limites du néolibéralisme où seule la
logique financière prime les victimes
économiques à de la crise pourrait être
tenté de descendre dans la rue il y à un
risque avéré de rapprochement entre
ultras radicaux et syndicats dans les
secteurs transport et énergie des pans
entiers de l'économie sont à l'arrêt
forcé et d'autres en profitent comme les
grands groupes
ce qui crée encore des raisons au
complotisme dernier point pour beaucoup
de français l'assignation à domicile et
le repli sur soi ont été difficiles à
vivre la famille n'étant pas toujours
une source de réconfort
preuve en est l'augmentation dès
violences conjugales courant avril
les associations de défense des femmes
avance une hausse de 30% lors du
confinement en particulier dans les
grandes métropoles le 11 mai va sonner
comme une libération des énergies pour
la plupart des mouvements contestataires
reste à savoir dans quelle mesure
et pour parler justement de ces
inquiétudes françois boulot avocat est
avec nous en direct bonsoir m merci
d'être avec nous on a entendu donc ses
inquiétudes sur l'après 11 mai sur 7
après confinement est ce que selon vous
ce sont des inquiétudes justifiées
oui bonsoir évidemment elles sont
justifiées ses inquiétudes parce que
s'ils ont des zooms un peu sur la
période sur quelques années on se rend
compte que cette crise sanitaire elle
est intervenue dans un contexte social
qui était déjà extrêmement explosif
on avait eu évidemment le mouvement des
gilets jaunes qui depuis le 17 novembre
2018 auxquels s'étaient ajoutés
le mouvement de grève l historique
contre la réforme des retraites ont tous
se souvient que le gouvernement il finit
avait dû utiliser le 49-3 qui avait mis
en colère énormément de gens
et finalement si cette réforme est
suspendu c'est à la faveur de cette
crise sanitaire donc on a une crise
sanitaire qui est venue s'ajouter à une
crise sociale et économique existante
pendant la crise sanitaire tout le monde
a vu que finalement c'était la
confirmation de la dénonciation des
politiques néolibérales qui était
conduite depuis des années qu'est-ce que
si nous sommes retrouvé démuni pour
faire face à la crise et bien c'est
parce que nous n'avions pas de masque
pas de test pas de moyens de protection
et les soignants en ont été évidemment
les premières victimes
eux qui est manifestée depuis plus d'un
an dans la rue donc finalement tous à
attiser la colère en plus de cela on a
ajouté les mensonge inouï du
gouvernement qui n'a cessé de mentir je
vais par contre tous les exemples mais
notamment sur les masques puisqu'il n'y
avait pas de masquer le gouvernement
nous expliquer que tu était inutile
d'emporter finalement on voit bien que
tout cela fait que toutes les crises
successives qui sont ensemble de naître
dans le pays depuis quelques années ne
sont jamais résolus et enfin on sait
désormais que évidemment le confinement
a mis en difficulté de manière très
grave et très profonde un certain nombre
d'entreprises d'artisans de commerçants
et également par voie de conséquence de
salariés donc il ya une catastrophe
économique qui s'annonce
il va y avoir des choix extrêmement
important sur le plan politique a opéré
et ce qui est à redouter c'est
finalement le pouvoir reste inflexible
comme il l'a toujours été et j'ai lu
très récemment
intervention d'emmanuel todd interview
d'emmanuel todd qui explique si vous
voulez que quand les gens vous ne leur
permettez pas de juger les responsables
et on voit qu'aujourd'hui il ya une loi
d'amnistié qui va être prise par le
pouvoir pour s'exonérer de toute
responsabilité pénale
si d'un côté vous empêchez les
responsables d'être jugés et que de
l'autre finalement les gens ne croient
plus en l'élection parce que quoi qu'il
arrive ce sont toujours les mêmes c'est
à dire des libéraux qui arrivent au
pouvoir
et bien finalement vous empêcher toute
possibilité d'un changement pacifique et
vous rêvez vous rendez donc inévitable
un changement qui s'effectuera dans des
conditions violentes
voilà le match nul au tout de même
l'état a été assez généreux pour
beaucoup d'observateurs rappellent que
la moitié des salariés dans le privé ont
été mis au chômage partiel avec des
aides notamment pour les plus modestes
également la réforme des retraites vous
l'avais dit à la faveur si j'ose dire de
cette crise qui a été donc abandonné
est-ce que tout de même ce n'est pas de
nature à infléchir un petit peu les
colères la colère des français
aujourd'hui selon vous je crois que les
mesures qui ont été prises étaient les
mesures minimales mais on l'a vu dans
votre reportage
il ya quelques instants il ya beaucoup
de personnes pour qui ces mesures sont
insuffisantes
c'est ce qu'il faut bien comprendre
c'est que pour l'instant nous ne sommes
qu'au début de cette crise économique
la déflagration qui va venir sera bien
plus importante ce qui fait qu'on va
avoir des choix extrêmement important à
faire emmanuel maintenant on va devoir
faire des choix
en gros la question va se poser de
savoir et se consomme le civiliste qu'on
sauve le système d'avant où est-ce qu'on
change de système
la première des conséquences c'est de
répondre à la question qui va payer les
conséquences de cette crise économique
est ce que ce sont toujours les mêmes
est ce que c'est la classe moyenne qui
va payer ou est ce que enfin ce sont les
ultra riches de ce pays qui vont payer
aujourd'hui il ya vincent lindon d'un
comédien qui a enregistré un appel et
qui a par exemple fait une proposition
extrêmement concrètes en indiquant qu'
on pourrait envisager que les gros
patrimoines c'était dans le patrimoine
est supérieur à 10 millions d'euros
et bien pour ça pour les hommes de
patrick qui dépasse 10 millions d'euros
il y aurait une taxe entre 1 et 5 % vont
déterminer mais sur le principe
voyez que ce serait la seule manière
effectivement d'éponger les conséquences
de cette crise sans faire
porter le poids des conséquences
sociales économiques désastreuses qui
vont déferler sur les gens qui sont
toujours les plus touchées les plus
précaires ou ceux qui payent toujours
les impôts dans ce prix est évidemment
il faudrait que cette taxe soit
accompagnée de mesures extrêmement
dissuasif en terme de sanction parce
qu'on sait qu'on ne pourra pas compter
sur la solidarité spontanée je dirais de
tous les ultra riches mais rose
merci beaucoup françois boulot d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france et
c'est la fin de cette émission un peu
courte et toujours en raison du
coronavirus tous les médias sont
contraints évidemment de s'adapter ça ne
devrait plus durer pour longtemps
prochain point sur l'actualité demain
matin 8 heures du matin heure française
se retrouve demain 20h pour une nouvelle
émission excédent de fin de soirée à
tous
[Musique]
je reçois john shipton le père de julien
assange fondateur de wikileaks est
actuellement derrière les barreaux à
londres selon les avocats du
gouvernement américain julian assange
aurait mis en danger la vie de ces
sources
ça casse c'est tout simplement faux
wikileaks coopérait avec 90 autres
organes d'information pour filtrer
expurgée et analyser les câbles à 65 ans
julian et son équipe ont essayé de
prévenir le département d'état mais on
les a ignorés qu'est-ce que ça on dit
sur la liberté d'expression d'après vous
notamment dans les pays occidentaux
il n'y a pas de liberté d'expression ça
il s'agit d' intimidation et
d'oppression des journalistes